per il lavoro che faccio qualche volta
la gente mi chiede come faccio a essere
creativa Come faccio a farmi venire le
idee
credo sia perché siamo abituati a
pensare alla creatività e
all'ispirazione come qualcosa che
colpisce all'improvviso quando meno te
lo aspetti e doverla produrre a comando
sembra un po' contro intuitivo ma avere
l'idea è solo una parte dell'essere
creativi e anche se forse al momento più
celebre più glorificato non racconta
tutta la storia
A me interessa parlare di quello che
succede dopo che si ha avuto l'idea
quando ci si addentra in quella che
chiamo la terra dei no
per come la vedo io la terra dei No è
abitata da due specie diverse i no che
dico io e no che mi dicono gli altri
Iniziamo da quelli che dico io
l'editing è uno dei momenti più
fondamentali della creatività c'è una
citazione talmente bella che è
attribuita simultaneamente a Mark Twain
e branding e Black Pascal in cui si
scusano di non aver avuto il tempo di
scrivere una lettera breve e per questo
di averne scritta una lunga Ora io non
so chi dei tre lo abbia detto per
davvero ma so che applico lo stesso
principio alla selezione delle idee
nel mio campo l'esperienza funziona un
po' al contrario ovvero di solito è
inversamente proporzionale al numero di
idee Creative che si presentano
se date lo stesso progetto ha un
creativo alle prime armi e a qualcuno
con molti anni di esperienza è quasi
certo che il creativo principiante
porterà più proposte questo non vuol
dire che sia più prolifico e abbia avuto
più idee significa solo che deve ancora
imparare a essere brutalmente selettivo
con il proprio lavoro
Insomma non ha ancora imparato a dirsi
di no
Non a caso uno dei migliori consigli che
si possa dare a un creativo è Kill your
darlings uccide i tuoi cari perché la
cosa più difficile non è tanto farsi
venire le idee ma evitare di
innamorarsene troppo
uno dei miei spot preferiti ha come
protagonista un uomo senza alcuna
esperienza davanti alla telecamera e non
l'avremmo mai trovato se non ci fossimo
impuntati a dire no
stavamo lavorando a un progetto per una
compagnia telefonica e cercavamo un uomo
tra i 40 e i 55 che fosse credibile nel
ruolo del protagonista
era la storia di un piccolo imprenditore
di una località turistica immaginatelo
un po' Don Chisciotte Un po' adorabile
pasticcione che aveva avuto l'idea di
addestrare i cani alla ricerca del wi-fi
Insomma una specie di versione moderna
del cane da tartufo e voleva addestrarli
per poi affittarle ai turisti che
cercavano la connessione per andare
online
Insomma era una storia bislacca e l'eroe
era altrettanto particolare quindi
azzeccare il ruolo era assolutamente
fondamentale
dopo settimane di casting in tre città
diverse non abbiamo ancora trovato
nessuno che ci convinca
abbiamo visto schiere di modelli ma sono
troppo perfetti poi vediamo tantissimi
attori anche molto bravi ma sembrano
troppo studiati vediamo anche un paio di
comici ma non funzionano sembrano
costruiti c'è una parte di me che vuole
essere ragionevole che vuole trovare una
soluzione abbiamo visto così tanti
candidati è possibile che non ce ne sia
uno che vada bene la mia pancia però
dice di no
spesso pensiamo alla creatività come a
qualcosa che esiste nella mente ma io
credo sia fatta molto di pancia
l'intestino è proprio biologicamente il
nostro secondo cervello e seguire la
pancia significa imparare ad ascoltare
quella vocina interna quell'intuizione
che ci dice che c'è ancora qualcosa che
non funziona del tutto che dobbiamo
continuare a cercare
Ed è proprio Grazie a questo ennesimo no
che la direttrice del casting
Probabilmente perché ormai al limite
della disperazione ci manda la foto di
un uomo incontrato per strada
letteralmente per strada perché era il
custode del parcheggio dove lei aveva
parcheggiato la macchina
troviamo così per puro caso la perfetta
incarnazione del nostro eroe
ora è rischioso reclutare qualcuno con
zero esperienza come protagonista di uno
spot Soprattutto uno spot pieno di
dialoghi e battute come era il nostro ma
credo sia ancora più rischioso sbagliare
il casting del protagonista per andare
sul sicuro
e così seguiamo la pancia e lo
scritturiamo all'istante
quello spot è diventato un grande
successo su YouTube ha scalato le
classifiche dei video più visti in
Germania e ha vinto diversi premi ai
Festival di creatività ironicamente
soprattutto per il casting
Insomma se la nostra pancia ci dice di
no Forse facciamo bene a fidarci ci sono
poi ovviamente i no che ci dicono gli
altri e in una carriera creativa è
inevitabile sentirsi dire di no in
continuazione il creatore di Sweet game
si è sentito rifiutare Lo script per
dieci anni Walt Disney si è beccato 30
No prima di trovare qualcuno che
credesse in Topolino
Insomma ci sono poche certezze nel
processo creativo a parte il rifiuto
trovare un modo di gestire il rifiuto è
necessario ma è anche molto complesso
soprattutto perché vivere il rifiuto in
modo positivo va proprio contro la
nostra natura
molti studi dimostrano che il dolore che
proviamo Quando veniamo rifiutati sia
tutti gli effetti simile al dolore
fisico
siamo una specie che si è evoluta
intorno all'accettazione sociale al
gruppo e viviamo il rifiuto come una
minaccia alla nostra sopravvivenza
quando ero ancora agli inizi ero andata
in pellegrinaggio a Milano per fare dei
colloqui con alcune famose agenzie di
pubblicità il che significa che ti siedi
alla scrivania del direttore creativo
nell'85% dei casi è un uomo nel 90% dei
casi è vestito completamente di nero e
gli fai vedere i tuoi lavori
ricordo che le agenzie erano tutte molto
diverse tra di loro Alcune erano parte
di grandi network internazionali altre
erano indipendenti Alcune erano molto
grandi altre erano piccole ma avevano
almeno una cosa in comune
risposero tutte no
difficile non prenderla sul personale
oggi però penso che quei no mi abbiano
costretta a trovare un'altra strada per
raggiungere il mio obiettivo insomma a
modo loro mi hanno costretta ad essere
creativa a stravolgere i miei piani ad
abbandonare l'idea di lavorare per
un'agenzia Milanese e fare qualcosa che
non avevo minimamente in programma
ovvero prendere e andare all'estero
col tempo lavorando in un settore in cui
mi sento regolarmente dire di no
ho dovuto trovare un meccanismo che mi
aiutasse a venire a Patti con il rifiuto
e a non viverlo sempre in modo
drammatico e così sorprendentemente sono
dovuta diventare ottimista perché devo
credere che la prossima idea possa
battere la precedente che esistano
infinite soluzioni allo stesso problema
e che quello che sarà possa essere
meglio di quello che è stato e questo mi
sembra un modo piuttosto bello di vedere
il futuro
qualche anno fa quando vivevo in
Germania avevamo iniziato a lavorare a
un corto per un noto Brand di macchine
Era una storia poco conosciuta che
risaliva a fine Ottocento ai tempi di
fondazione del brand e raccontava come
dietro al successo del fondatore che era
l'inventore della prima automobile ci
fosse sua moglie
era stata lei a credere nell'idea
dell'automobile quando nessun altro ne
capiva l'utilità lei a investire i suoi
soldi nel prototipo lei ad affrontare il
primo viaggio della storia su lunga
distanza in una specie di geniale gesto
di marketing che una volta per tutte
aveva dimostrato il potenziale
dell'invenzione del marito
Insomma era una storia importante per il
Brand ma era una storia importante anche
culturalmente perché offriva un dovuto
riconoscimento storico a questa
incredibile figura femminile
poco prima di girare un collega mi manda
un link lo apro e vedo che un'altra
agenzia appena realizzato lo stesso
identico spot per il cliente americano
battendoci sul tempo
in un'industria in cui l'originalità è
il comandamento numero 1 questa equivale
a un no gigantesco
oppure sì il pubblicitario britannico
John every sostiene che il nostro lavoro
sia 80% idea e 80 per cento esecuzione
La forza della creatività non sta solo
nell'avere una nuova idea ma anche nel
risolvere lo stesso problema nel mio
caso nel raccontare la stessa identica
storia in un modo del tutto originale in
fondo ci sono dozzine di film che
raccontano la storia di Batman e così
quello spot lo abbiamo girato comunque e
a confronto i due non potevano essere
più diversi
un'ora in bianco e nero Il nostro era
colori uno Aveva come musica un
pianoforte piuttosto malinconico mentre
il nostro aveva una composizione
orchestrale vagamente sinistra
inquietante Uno era una favola Il nostro
era un dramma proprio incentrato sul
conflitto Uno era un tributo storico a
questa donna Il nostro invece è un film
ambientato nell'Ottocento che però aveva
un messaggio contemporaneo
era la stessa storia Sì ma il contributo
creativo dell'Agenzia del regista dello
scenografo del costumista Insomma di
tutte le persone che partecipano al
progetto del genere Lo hanno trasformato
in un film completamente diverso
succede poi che il nostro spot raccolga
milioni di visualizzazioni succede che
ne scrivano i media di tutto il mondo e
che diventi uno degli spot più premiati
quell'anno a livello internazionale
ovviamente fa piacere ma io non posso
fare a meno di ripensare a quel bivio a
quel momento in cui avremmo potuto
rinunciare fermarci dire no perché senza
dubbio restare nella terra dei no
sarebbe stato più comodo sarebbe stato
meno rischioso ci avrebbe fatto dormire
sonni più tranquilli
Ma come dicevo prima il bello di essere
creativi è che sei costretta a diventare
ottimista Grazie